in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Barack
and Lydia are with us hey guys how are
you good
welcome welcome where do you all live
Wow Oh fun very cool welcome to
Nashville thank you and you're here to
do a debt free scream yes we are how
much have you paid off a hundred and
thirty five thousand my goodness and
what how long did that take thirty two
months cool making a range of income of
what household we started out around 130
and then it went up 260 and then down to
150 okay cool what do you guys do for a
living I'm a PA okay I'm awesome very
cool so what kind of debt was a hundred
and thirty ously school yeah one hundred
and ten of it was uh school loans and
then the rest was credit-card debt I got
you okay so what happened to you guys I
mean what happened thirty two months ago
and you decided to go obviously you went
crazy
I mean you've lived on nothing to pull
this off tell me the story what happened
how did you get started well it actually
started a few months before that for
Christmas my mother-in-law gave me the
Total Money Makeover hint aunt yes and
it was funny at the time I saw it I
didn't know who you were and I was a
little bit offended but you know I read
the book and it would just on a budget
we got on a plan together you know on
the same page and yeah we've been
cooking since then so soul idiot your
mother gives your husband a book he
reads the book yeah and he comes in and
goes we're about to change the whole
deal what do you say well so we actually
at the time to save money we had decided
to drive together to work so we listened
to your books on cassette so we both got
on the same okay all right so you were
getting it at the same time yes so I was
annoyed about his spending he was
annoyed about mine and then we just got
annoyed about each other's and decided
to change it then we just got more
annoyed yeah there we go and now we're
annoyed yeah we are very keen knew who
you were I had no idea she's like you
know he's on the radio he's really funny
I'm like I don't know I'm at work my dad
calls you Dave Rambo oh okay well I'll
take it that way that's fun well
congratulations you guys I mean you got
with it this is pretty serious numbers
that you moved around did you sell stuff
we sold her motorcycle we cashed in a
whole life plan but what did those two
things bring two grand
yes yeah and then the whole life was
okay 7,000 there is most of it though
you cashflow yeah before the whole life
thing was one of the things her
grandparents set up for and so there's
kind of an emotional attachment there
but you know they told her they told her
grandma that you know my time she's an
adult you have a million dollars or
whatever was yeah completely
yeah all right you guys well very fun so
what do you tell people the key to
paying off a hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars and thirty two months
is I think the biggest thing is to you
know obviously the budget but just to be
on the same page you know you had just
been mutually annoyed prior talking
about it talking about everything
because we like to spend on different
things and why did you spend on then why
did you buy that that's a typical
marriage fight yeah yeah that's pretty
normal we've never done that at our
house yeah so did it help the
communication then because there was
kind of this to this bowl I'm hearing a
little bit and then that starts to go
away when you're working together yeah
okay yeah and then you know we could
talk about things and say well you know
this is greed on this is a plan this is
what we're headed so mutually would you
might have made a contract and that
keeps you in the boundary line yeah okay
very cool very cool what was the hardest
part of this for y'all I think the
hardest part was after our daughter was
born I went part-time so that we could
always have someone home with her mm-hmm
and so you know Lidia work in the
emergency room her hours are all over
the place and we really didn't give us
each other for like it was nice
yeah you know we're handing her off and
that was it
how's our interaction so that's why the
income went up and down and back okay
all right that makes sense
yeah but you did all of that to pay a
price to be able to get that cleared up
so how does it feel to not have any
payments pretty amazing it's amazing
there's a release in there yes when you
hit that submit button and Sallie Mae
has given her eviction notice it just
there's a weight gone in there yeah
congratulations you guys thank you it's
an honor to have you very cool all right
Barack and Lydia and Ruby Ruby I hear is
in the background how old is Ruby 21 21
months perfect
that's very cool Oh cute cute cute cute
that's fun all right you guys ought to
be watching this on the television
screen you get to see a cute kid that
pebbles look that's awesome
very cool all right Barack and Lydia
from the Dayton Ohio area a hundred and
thirty-five thousand dollars paid off in
32 months making 130 to 150 during that
time count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
that's great you guys are fun very very
well done
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you